GOVERNOR'S ELECTION TOMORROW.
MATT BEVIN ON THE SHOW IS UP.
THE BEST-SELLING AUTHOR
MARK STEYN WATCHING THE RALLY
SINCE THE BEGINNING TONIGHT.
HE JOINS US TO DISCUSS, MARK,
WHAT DID YOU THINK?
>> WELL, I WAS THINKING
SOMETHING INTERESTING ABOUT
TRUMP'S RALLIES, TUCKER.
THE TOTAL QUALITY.
FOR ME, IT WAS INTERESTING WHEN
HE DECIDED TO TAKE IT TO
JOE BIDEN WITH THAT BIT ABOUT
HOW HANDLERS ARE -- AND
JOE BIDEN HE SAID, THE GUIDE
COMES ON AND SAYS, HI AMONG FOLS
COMES ON AND SAYS, HI AMONG FOL,
THAT'S ALL IT GOT TIME FOR, AND
THEN FOR HANDLERS HUSTLING
HIM OFF OF THE STAGE BEFORE FOR
IOWA.
IN THE GREAT QUESTION, THE GREAT
QUESTION FOR THE DEMOCRATS IN
2020 IS WHETHER THE NORMAL
RULES AND CONVENTIONS OF
PRESIDENTIAL POLITICS, WHICH I
FIND BORING AS ANYTHING, AND I
THINK MOST REAL PEOPLE DO, CAN
RECONSIDER COMES I PAY OR THAT
IS THE CHOICE IF YOU NOMINATE
BIDEN.
THAT YOU TAKE THE STIFF WHOSE
TURN IT IS AND THE HANDLE THAT'S
DRAGGING HIM ACROSS THE FINISH
LINE.
IT IS INTERESTING TO ME THAT
TRUMP SAID, NO, I WILL WIN OR
LOSE IN 2020.
AND TRUMP COME I'M GOING TO LET
TRUMP BE TRUMP.
IN THIS BUSINESS WITH HANDLERS
ARE FOR WITNESSES.
THE QUESTION IS WHETHER
JOE BIDEN IF ANYTHING WILL
HANDLE ANYTHING THAT CAN SUIT --
CONSISTENTLY PUSH BACK.
>> Tucker: IT IS HARD TO
BELIEVE AFTER THE EXPENSE OF
2016.
WE FOCUS ON REPUBLICANS THAT
DOMINATED THE FEEL AND WON IN
THE END.
THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE, AND AN
ENORMOUSLY BITTER CONTEST WHERE
THE POPULAR CANDIDATE
BERNIE SANDERS LOST, THANKS TO
RIGGING BY THE DEMOCRATIC
ESTABLISHMENT.
THAT WOUND NEVER REALLY DID
HEAL.
SO YOU ARE TELLING ME THAT THAT
PARTY IS GOING TO DO THE SAME
THING AGAIN REPLACING HILLARY
WITH JOE BIDEN AND
ELIZABETH WARREN AND BERNIE WILL
STAND THERE AND TAKE IT?
DO YOU REALLY THINK THAT WILL
HAPPEN?
>> WELL, I THINK THEY WERE
SERIOUS ABOUT NURSE MEETING
JOE BIDEN WITH A DEBATE WITH
TRUMP.
IF YOU LOOK AT LAST TIME AROUND,
TRUMP HIMSELF WAS BEING SLIGHTLY
HOUSETRAINED AND THE HANDLE
DURING THOSE DEBATES WITH
HILLARY.
>> Tucker: .
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> WHAT WE SEE IN THESE DEBATES,
WHAT WE SEE IN THESE RALLIES IS
WE SEE HIM LIBERATING.
AND SOMETIMES THAT WORKS
INGENIOUS WAYS AND IT IS TRUE
JUST IMPROVISED THE LINE ABOUT
PRE-EXISTING POSITIONS.
IT MAKES IT QUITE ENVIOUS OF ME.
THAT IS AN IMPRESSIONABLE, THAT
IS A PROFESSIONAL LINE.
AND I DON'T, NOW, I'M KICKING
MYSELF, WHAT IS IT, NINE YEARS
AGO WHEN THEY RAMPED OBAMACARE
DOWN THE THROATS OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THEY SAID IF YOU LIKE IT YOU CAN
KEEP YOUR DOCTOR BUT I WISH I
HAD COME UP WITH PRE-EXISTING
CONDITIONS, BUT NOT PAY
EXISTING POSITION -- CONDITIONS.
SOMETIMES THAT IS A GENIUS TO
LET HIM STAND THERE AND
ROCK 'N' ROLL.
SOMETIMES HE WILL SAY THINGS
LIKE WHEN HE WAS CITING OUR
FRIEND LOU DOBSON'S OPINION,
TRUMP IS NOT JUST A GREAT
PRESIDENT BUT GREATER THAN
RIGGING, GREATER THAN LINCOLN,
GREATER THAN WASHINGTON.
AND YOU THINK TO YOURSELF, MAYBE
THAT'S NOT THE SORT OF THING A
PROVEN MAN SAYS ABOUT HIMSELF,
BUT YOU TAKE HIM AND YOU HAVE TO
TAKE HIM IN FULL.
AND THEY ARE BETTING THAT IN
FULL, HE BEATS WHATEVER THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE.
AND THAT, YOU HAVE SEEN THE
CONFIDENCE OF THE T-SHIRTS
STANDING BEHIND HIM OF PEOPLE
WEARING T-SHIRTS SAYING, RING
THE TRIP DOMINIC READ THE
TRANSCRIPTS.
HE SPECTRA DAN THE HOUSE WILL
IMPEACH ME, SO WHAT?
AND IN THAT SENSE, HE'S BEING
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT, FOR
EXAMPLE THE WAY BILL CLINTON
REACTED TO IMPEACHMENT 20 YEARS
AGO.
>> Tucker: WHICH IS TO IGNORE
WHAT WAS HAPPENING.
ONE THING HE IS NOT IGNORING
THAT EVERYONE ELSE IN THE MEDIA
IS IGNORING IS WHAT IS HAPPENING
TO THE CITY OF CALIFORNIA.
LOOK COME I WANT TO PLAY THIS
CLIP.
PELOSI ON THIS QUESTION, HERE IT
IS.
>> NANCY OUGHT TO STOP WASTING
TIME, GO BACK TO HER DISTRICT IN
SAN FRANCISCO, HELP THE
HOMELESS, GET RID OF THE DRUGS,
GET RID OF THE NEEDLES THAT ARE
LYING ALL OVER THE STREET, AND A
LIVE THE THINGS THAT ARE WASHING
INTO THE OCEAN THROUGH THE POOR
SEWER SYSTEM.
WHAT HAS HAPPENED IN
SAN FRANCISCO AND WHAT HAS
HAPPENED TO SO MANY OTHER PLACES
RAN BY THE RADICAL LEFT
DEMOCRATS, IT IS UNBELIEVABLE.
>> Tucker: IT JUST STRIKES ME,
NOBODY ELSE IS TALKING ABOUT
THIS BUT HIM.
>> AND YOU, TUCKER, BECAUSE YOU
NOTICED YOUR STATE, CALIFORNIA,
ISN'T SO GOLDEN.
IT IS ACTUALLY CITIES TURNING
INTO A DECREPIT, THIRD WORLD
CITIES WHERE FLESH EATING
DISEASES AND TUBERCULOSIS AND
HUMAN FETAL MATTER IS ON THE
STREETS.
AND THIS, HE HAS RIGHT TO HANG
THIS AROUND THEIR NECK.
IF YOU GO TO NANCY PELOSI IN
SAN FRANCISCO, IT GOT WORSE ON
NANCY'S WATCH.
AND THAT'S WHAT SHE WANTS TO DO
TO AMERICA.
>> Tucker: THE MIDDLE CLASS